good morning Millennials happy Friday
start again because it's Monday in three
two one
good morning Millennials happy Monday
it's such a monday e monday here in LA
and Elizabeth's okay we are here with
influencer youtuber like fashion
designer and toaster Lauren Elizabeth oh
friend and sibling at this point you say
thank you
sister we have had a wonderful week in
LA with you we've had so much fun we did
yes not over even though it's Monday
you know it's money do you have a
Thursday dinner tonight we yes
technically you guys as you know
probably it is Thursday but we are
filming Monday's episode because we
wouldn't be able to give you an episode
from New York together so we figured
we'd treat you with a morning toast
special edition episode this episode
much like Passover is gonna be unlike
all episodes because there's no SAS 5
today because why would we give you news
on Thursday when you're watching on
Monday and 2 we have a bevy of
announcements and I think I want to
start with the most exciting one because
it's not just a coincidence that Lauren
is on the show today
we have such a special project that we
can announce secret project announcement
coming soon yeah and we're getting hard
oh my god we've been out really annoying
like have we know i-i've made sure we
were as least annoying as possible we
are way too self-aware to be annoying
okay like yeah come on like we like
triple check everything we say that's
sure well you have gotten so many GM's
about starting a podcast mainly from me
and Jackie and when we really became
good friends which was that stage coat
yes Jackie and I were like really
thirsty to be your friend but like we're
also thirsty business women we were
thirsty to be in business so we were
actually all in the car together when
you came to our you out in our cardinal
someday right to go from the revolve
party to actual festival and you were
talking about a podcast me and Jackie
were texting each other in the car like
what should we be get the off Olivia
Olivia your sister was the one that was
like um I think they wouldn't like ask
you something or like asking someone out
on a date yeah no and yeah like people
in LA are like so weird like you never
know what they're gonna say and like so
from
LS business with pleasure it's not
something that's you know typically
advised advised but in this instance
it's such an exciting time because
without further ado we would like to
present our newest toast news network
podcast show mood with Lauren Elizabeth
the crowd goes wild this is your mood
about it can you tell us a little bit
about in behind your name choice we went
through a lot of names well yes we went
through a lot of names and I mean we've
been like what like talking about this
since stage code by now it's like almost
end of the year and I it's funny because
I actually was doing something in the
beverage department and thought of the
name mood because it's like such a
trendy word and I was like there's so
much you can do with it with like
marketing and like talking about
something and I couldn't get it
trademarked and so then I tabled it and
it was something I was doing with
Cameron and so literally at brunch on
Saturday I was like um as I tell you
something he was like what I was like I
actually forgot to tell you the name my
podcast he was like what is it I was
like well I got this trademark since my
name's in it it's called mood with
Lauren Elizabeth he's a great [ __ ] and I
was like well I thought of it like if I
[ __ ] word yours but I mean the
inspiration mostly what came behind is
that like it's like the same thing but I
live in LA but I'm not very LA but like
sometimes I am and like sometimes I'm
hungover sometimes I'm like super
healthy it's just like there's so many
different moods which I boyfriend is
like yeah like basically you're starting
a podcast based on like you being
[ __ ] psychotic and bipolar a hundred
percent yeah so it just basically gives
me the opportunity to not pigeonhole
myself and do like having a real
profession and just get to talk [ __ ] on
my career yeah it's like it's like each
week is a different mood like are we
feeling like we want to drop some wisdom
are we feeling like we want to talk [ __ ]
like yeah mood lets you do whatever is
popular all encompassing exactly well we
thought your podcast would be such a
good idea because anyone who follows you
like you really have such an interesting
life and I don't know I just want to
know more about it and I feel like
that's why there's been a lot of demand
from your followers from YouTube and
Instagram for you to launch a podcast
it's klister I was like doing cool and
interesting things and like you're
always invited to revolve like we need a
roof
behind-the-scenes podcast honest we need
like revolve Napa recaps and we're gonna
get those with mood and also like now
that we have the podcast and we've
decided we're taking it on the go like
we're not gonna do it in studio which we
in our big business meeting about right
before two minutes ago on the floor we
decided and it's like I could bring my
like podcast equipment to look over
evolve Napa and I can't even on the
scene you can get us some premium but
yes I have like I like I don't get a fun
no she like so many girls in LA will
like come up she like pretend like
there's your name I'm like [ __ ] it's
like my Instagram photo like and I'm
just like just say hi like I will go up
to someone like I sat next to Kaitlyn
Bristowe for the first time like meeting
her and I was like hi oh my god like
you're the reason I started watching The
Bachelor at like oh my god slut-shaming
ha you've come so far
like I'm Lauren how are you it's like
holy [ __ ] yeah but it's like no shame
look we're gonna get premium gas it's
very refreshing in LA that type of
attitude yeah that's why I say my house
a lot yeah me too which is why we're
recording [ __ ] at some house your house
is your vibe is a mood everything about
you is a mood and I feel as though when
you're like a fan of yours which is how
I started out knowing that you were a
toaster then I started like delving into
your stuff and now you're one of the few
video people that I watch on YouTube you
you can tell I don't watch a lot of
YouTube stuff because I'm saying video
people you're a grandma trying to use a
[ __ ] grandma but it's like you have
this whole like brand and personality on
YouTube but then you hang out with you
in person and it's like you're such an
it girl it's this interesting the name
we actually wanted for the podcast we
started I said [ __ ] she said to herself
hasn't it that's the thing about it
girls like they'll never admit that
they're eight girls which is why they
have it you know that's a statement they
all day that were eight girls because
well but because they're any model but
honestly like now that I think about it
like I feel like I'm the definition of a
night girl like not to make this about
me but I'm just saying are a great girl
I should call a podcast called it
comesss I'm it's s yeah you are it I
don't know if you're the girl no I think
I am there's a lot of times with that
term you were laughing oh my god we have
to recap Wednesday night in LA we will
get there well should we recap it
whatever okay I'm so confused with these
days you know it's like we do everything
live that we are actually spazzing out
and we're acting like we're doing
something so crazy when 90% of the
podcasters of the world that will
accordin episode in January and pretend
it's December like everyone does it but
like we're so true in real time that I
feel like a fraud yeah yeah I feel like
a fraud everyday though okay that's your
mood of the day so we're gonna dive in I
won that you look a little expose on you
because I feel like as much as I'm like
one of your best friends I like to
consider even though like you refer to
other people as your best friend
Instagram stories um I feel like I
actually locate know nothing about you
so interesting that you say that I feel
like I'm always learning new things
about you and I want to take today to
learn so much more yeah it's like we I
feel like we hit it off so hard so fast
yeah that we initially became sisters
and then like we just like have like so
much fun that at the same time like
we're just like talking about like
everything besides herself oh it's so
true and it's like we we really are
gonna go beneath the surface on this
outside okay excuse me everybody to stop
drinking fountain soda during podcast
episodes okay Wow okay also like you
have a huge audience as a youtuber
influencer toasters who are watching
this now who are looking for more
podcast content because you know the
workday never and never again I mean as
a toaster like you guys when it's like
oh my god we're doing 60 minutes I'm
like give me 72 like like I literally
just finished the episode with Morgan
Stewart and I almost like listen to the
last five minutes again cuz I still
wasn't here it was so good too but then
I know I put then I put on Kaitlyn
Bristowe podcast but soon you'll be able
to put on mood by Lauren Elizabeth yes
by the way is launching Wednesday of
this week two days
you got to subscribe know tell all your
friends share it on Twitter share it on
Instagram share it on Facebook share it
on tik-tok oh it's got a move it's gonna
be a bit alone and then Wednesday the
first episode drops everyone's really
looking forward to it we gathered
questions from all corners of the
internet for you because you really have
led like so many lives like you you just
have like so many moods I so ease so
we're gonna jump in but not before I let
you guys know who today's episode is
brought to you by and Lauren your
podcasts are in the making and you got
to know how to do a good read and here's
how it's done hmm I've actually always
wanted to see this without further ado
today's episode is brought to you by
noon a habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food food excuse me
through personalized courses that fruit
stuff based on psychology Noom teaches
you why the bad things you do and arm
mmm okay
toriel okay basically newsy on let me
show her at seven please okay okay
new ms a wonderful online platform that
really helps you get yourself in check
it will help you achieve specific goals
that you want to achieve and it's not
just about losing weight there you can
achieve better self-care making
healthier choices feeling more confident
in clothing having more energy or just
an overall glow i'm you to learn how to
stop feeling confident in clothing
because I think I look amazing and then
I see a picture and I'm like who is that
okay well at least like you feel good
right and Sony's
in thanks Junu in thanks to noon we've
been loving new for so long and it
really is a habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses what we always say
about new mates basically like the toast
an online community that makes you feel
safe and it's gonna help you better
yourself and new me is not a diet it's a
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
it also it's a mood yeah for sure first
and the best part is you are human they
know that if you go off track there's no
shaming just tips to help you get back
on track tomorrow I love it and you will
too you don't have to change it all in
one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon and
oom calm / toast what do you have to
lose
visit longing your maid visit noon
dot-com / toast to start your trial
today that's Noom dot-com / toast the
last weight loss program you'll need
inspiring or in person yeah Oh does it
yeah use cards doesn't know I don't skip
through because like you something will
happen yeah yeah it's like the only ads
I don't skip through I want to get
through my own oh yeah oh yeah that's a
big endorsement let's check it back to
the beginning okay Lauren Elizabeth
you're from Chicago a small-town girl
mall town steensma and you somehow ended
up in LA getting big youtuber to the
stars revolve around the world but how
did you really get like your when did
you decide to move to LA and what had
you been doing up until that that made
you think like it would be a good idea
for you to move to LA okay I'm gonna
compress this because you're him no no
no no but like you know how to say this
like you're so many today yeah it's the
stick in coal mine was different mine
was um I was in high school and I got
grounded because I was grounded a lot I
mean
like a bad child I was a bad girl do
anything it was just I went to a small
private Catholic High School and I would
like dancing class and like it attention
like you
oh yeah like did stripper pole dance
like do it like like I was like a
flosser kid like wow yeah is class class
okay and always late and whatever so I
was grounded for god knows what reason
maybe you know drinking underage and my
mom caught me in whatever dancing class
well it was a beer and I was like free
sips and Kathleen rat me out so Kathleen
who's that what in the Anna group has
shed say her name
Kathleen darling Kathleen darling how
dare you yeah it was it was a big deal
but I was grounded and my mom was like
why don't you do something with your
life start a blog and I was like you're
so [ __ ] stupid I'm slam the door and
then they're what used to be a software
where you could make blogs on Apple
which doesn't exist anymore what was it
called I know it was like you know how
you get the thing it's like iMovie
Safari like all the things that come
with it there was like a I web or
something I was like playing around with
it guy was like really good at MySpace
like I was always at coding and stuff
and then I started my blog in high
school and I was writing about like
fashion and there was like a little bit
Mussoorie subject for me that lolu
fully-loaded because lo was my nickname
lu stands for my last name solo lu and
then fully-loaded because it was fully
loaded with all things fashion and
beauty I don't think it's so bad so bad
but like I get like made fun of it like
a lot like okay that's like the worst
thing early are charmed let's just wait
till you go to my YouTube channel you
know like reverse it to like oldest to
newest oh yeah that's that's work I
can't believe I just I'm actually gonna
go do that one no like okay can we at
least do it at my house so like I get to
like guide you through the process okay
anyway so did the blog realize like oh
writing out some things is hard but it
would be easier to film them on camera
started filming the these ones are down
like the shittiest like embarrassing
like smokey eye tutorial like like I
don't know how to do a smokey eye what
was I thinking
I don't know then I saw some girl do the
cold what's in my bag video and I was
like oh like that looks like I could do
that that looks fun so it really became
like the creative outlet in high school
like I quit I was on like a competitive
cheerleading team in high school
I quit because I just like wasn't
be and I was like okay this is my new
hobby
and it was such a different platform
that like I started making friends and
like reach like if you comment like how
we became Internet friends like you
could do that in like YouTube comments
and there was like messages and stuff
yeah so I just did it all the rest of
high school I was like the first one to
be on Twitter the first wouldn't be on
Instagram got so made fun of in high
school like Bailey oh yeah they like
would pull up my what to call they would
hope my video sound like the projector
and stuff like that and like I also just
like I would my claim to fame is how to
out combat boots but if you do rocket
combat it's like me in my backyard like
with different outfits like my brother
like go like panning up and down and I
was like yeah he's at my house I'm so
excited you're gonna love him he's like
way cooler than me I can't believe like
you were bullied you know what I mean
cuz I could yeah you like so but like to
this day like girls from my high school
like shout out if you're listening so I
know that there's so many toasters in
the Midwest like we'll DM me being like
oh is that your version of the story
sweetheart not how it went down
and I'm like literally still bullying me
like I want to go to the college
counselor eyeliner I'm your close friend
story and I remember when you posted oh
hi guys feel me you don't understand one
of the girls did one of Lauren's bullies
like DM her like literally bullying her
about the bullying like it was so close
like here almost 30 did a [ __ ] lie no
it's so crazy
oh no great it's just so funny cuz if
you look at someone like you like you
just are so pretty and cute like you
would think like you were the one
bullying someone you know like it
definitely was no but it's like either
the video was on the projector or it
wasn't I understand there's two sides to
every story but the video was on the
projector on the friend that's so
[ __ ] rude and they weren't watching
it like to learn yeah best friends
pushed me in the hallway licked me off
and then brother Rob shoutouts brother
Rob I had to go to the counselor's
office to talk about like the bullies
yes I had to go see counselors nature
and I had to go get like I had to like
make amends with like one of these girls
or whatever but it wasn't as much the
YouTube it was more just like I just
like I I call my high school like going
to like a frat like that's what I said
on instruments like going to a frat like
every was it just really cut
like in me my girlfriends were saying
like do they not remember that we had to
have like school-wide bullying meetings
everyone was just so [ __ ] mean to
each other that like it's like when
Taylor started like writing songs in
high school like and she would think she
would be so popular because she was like
getting kind of famous and she was like
this tall beautiful model and she was
made fun of like to no extent where she
like couldn't go to school anymore yeah
they're so jealous I stopped going to
school like senior year I went for like
two periods and then I would go home and
like work on my blog and then like go my
mom would drive me down to the city and
I would go to like events and stuff and
she was like my like little publicist
that is like honestly so cool of you but
I feel like if you got bullied for
something like that like you have to
love it so much to keep doing oh yeah
some people would be like oh my god I
don't want my video on the projector
again I'm not I literally said I was
like you know it was a creative outlet
when you go back and you look at my
videos and there's one with me with big
blue feathered earrings and I go hey
guys I just got gum surgery so I'm home
for the day and I figured talk about my
favorite spring fashion trend any free
time right now I wouldn't [ __ ] upload
a video now that [ __ ] I gotta make a
video you really like but it was like it
was just my hobby and I started making
friends by the time you left high school
how many subscribers did you have oh um
probably I don't I think maybe a hundred
okay well I think I don't know for sure
because I know that when I moved to LA I
had like in the hundreds like below 500
but over 100k and when did you move to
LA I moved to I went to college for a
year and I was just the digital it
wasn't where it is now obviously but
like we were starting to get a little
bit more of opportunities that comes
doing hosting stuff cuz I was going to
school for broadcast journalism where in
at Columbia colleges in DePaul
University okay and so I was getting all
these like kind of opportunities and
then like also YouTube was getting brand
deals at the time which has changed so
much but I was like okay everything was
this summer we're like everyone moved to
LA like I'm not kidding you like every
person with a [ __ ] YouTube channel no
matter where they were on the country
were like moving to Los Angeles and I
was like I gotta go yeah and my mom's
like super super supportive and so she
was like okay like I guess look whatever
like go for it I moved here when I was
at the two days after I turned 19 but I
started the way that I was able to do it
is I got an internship at awesomeness TV
I used it for school credit and so I
wasn't just like moving out here for
like YouTube was like I was like yeah I
was like I'm trying to get into the
entertainment industry and I have this
platform and I'd never I wasn't fully
out of school or fully unemployed until
like I was doing well enough to not have
a full-time job did you graduate college
no cuz I got busy that and I got hired
as an employee so I was like a full-time
employee for like a month and a half
what was that conversation like telling
your mom that you were piecing out of
college um I kind of was just like can I
do this and she's like yeah that's so
crazy that's what we were just talking
about a lady getting podcast this week
when we recorded it with them how like
literally nobody's successful graduated
college I were the morons who went to
college and paid for it I always forget
well that was my thing too is like I
what's called my brother has a
scholarship he's like super smart and
then like Here I am I'm like I was the
[ __ ] dumbest part like I was like the
biggest black sheep like idiot out of my
family until this whole like a YouTube
thing happened but what's a call I was
about to like start having like college
tuition bills and I was like wait but
I'm making my own money now why would I
be putting it into [ __ ] college like
it's just what I want to be investing in
yeah I was like if I need to come back
I'll come back like I never clicked the
drop out button right I just like fills
out in I'm still a student like honestly
like I'm still a freshman I know but
it's like you could take you the money
you're making on YouTube and buy like
wait all new equipment or you could
spend it on college we're just gonna sit
there for four hours a week like doing
nothing well I also just bought us I
think I bought a saline bag and like
drained my bank a'course when I was like
19 I was like I need the luggage to know
what was the first thing I'm starting at
like when you started doing YouTube
full-time where you where was the first
opportunity you made money like the
first time someone emailed you offering
like oh I will never forget the first
time I made money off my Instagram cuz I
couldn't believe it I felt like I was
cheating the world
I don't know I'm like literally like you
a guy like do I don't remember anything
but actually my work was a thousand
dollars from Burger King and like I
really eat it all in one place yeah I'm
sure it was like probably when I was
like that first year of college and
there was like these like random like
weird like stores that would like pay
like a little bit like a video or
something that's cool yeah but it wasn't
like substantial yet and also like
monetization was like big like you could
like turn the ads on your videos and
stuff and like we used to be able to use
music in our
like so basically in the past like six
months that we've all been getting
emails from like all of our old videos
being like Universal has claimed your
video like it's no longer yes this of
all these videos so I'll get like 50
emails a day when like so-and-so claimed
your video on like [ __ ] there goes that
one right but I like whatever that sucks
yeah I don't make a lot of money off
monetization so I love a good brand deal
YouTube was making some drama like a
couple weeks ago with them like
unverified you tube talent like they
unverified Jake Paul and a bunch of
other people yeah I was following all
the trauma on pop crave Twitter um and
then they decide it's like reinstate it
were you affected by that at all if I
was I wouldn't know are you verified on
youtube I don't know so much of a thing
I didn't know that that was the thing it
is it is a we see I have a question for
you you're a big youtuber we go live on
YouTube every single day what can we do
to optimize what we're doing over here
at the morning toes yeah we have no
subscribers okay hello everyone
hello tell your friend we need to go 200
I mean I think this would be do like a
larger conversation for a business
meeting but you don't do thumbnails okay
100 percent you need thumbnails also
because I have no idea like what each
one cuz like I'm subscribed to you guys
but I always listen on podcast I think I
don't even know like what's like what's
what they always look the same but I
think it's good that you changed that
but so titles your enjoying I'm enjoying
that okay I know some posters weren't
enjoying that well actually can't please
everyone ever everyone ever ever but I
mean it's helpful cuz like then I
actually know like what's going on like
I'm the YouTube thing too but I think
like you know there's some premium
content that you could be making on
YouTube give us a three step you to
bought it thumbnails what else could we
be doing thumbnails I mean gets put like
the tags in tag so some money hash tag
comedy has no job I do like hash tag
other shows that if you watch that you
would like this you don't do hash tag
you don't need to hash tag so look
there's tag always do tags I don't okay
so I think you can do both now which is
weird but yeah and then it says like I
don't if people saw what I tagged her if
you don't know like sarin or there's a
program that like they can see it and
like there's like these like troll like
youtubers and they'll [ __ ] who did it so
I was like oh like her third tag is like
blah blah blah so now I felt so
self-conscious what did you use to tag
like
I do like Beauty Hall lifestyle and then
I'm like boyfriend dating Los Angeles
and then I'm like a deserted do I talk
about anyone famous like oh good morning
Joey like la ville Agra bloggers like
rama revolve like drawing that I think
that's so funny I would go public with
our tax like there's nothing like that
crazy but it's just like laying I don't
ya know it's like super lame like you're
just Li trying to get people to click
and it's like embarrassing it's so how
many podcast morning show millennial
show that's the blotchy always live the
comedy like yeah and then I go down a
rabbit hole Blake watcher happens live
Bravo enews eonline daily pop nightly
pop Morgan Stewart no sorry illness like
you like these people yeah I feel like
these people you like us but I think you
guys could definitely do thumbnails ok
and then just also like do you even like
promo oh yes no we could do more like
highlights you know just like yeah
pertinent clips in episode and just like
cute like mashups and [ __ ] I don't yeah
yeah okay okay don't have the manpower
for that snitch snitch on the tube so
you move to LA you've been doing this
full-time for what like five years well
I started in 2011 it so yeah which is
like so sad and then when did you launch
XLE which is her branded you should shop
at at shop clothing and clothing was a
year ago now so this will be our second
like fall drop so like last year was our
first and it's just you know it's moving
in a groove and it's really hard to run
a business that's like with with
physical products like yeah inventory
stock like all this [ __ ] like
speaking of thinking of there's no
special announcement there's are you I
mean there is a restock of morning toast
merch today at 3 p.m. Eastern Time which
gives everyone fair time to set the
alarms West Coast people you should be
up by noon 3 o'clock Eastern Time get
your merch all of the apparel that sold
out in minutes is being restocked
ordered literally 10 times the
quantities I'm telling you it's not
gonna sell out ok it's not if it's sold
out like I would fall on the floor I
need Life Alert yeah I did Life Alert
this would be a great time to do a read
for Life Alert
which we're not doing but we are telling
you that restock is today at 3 o'clock
p.m. Eastern time get your merge the
teal sweater is back this sweaters back
that sweaters back this snatcher comes
over you know
the camera she's got that late night
long-sleeved t-shirt and it is a good
one this one sold out first and fastest
and I was really surprised by that
oh wow just gonna walk right through
turn give us the front move your hair
and do a little twirl for us show them
the back can't shunt and when this merch
shop was just so premium I hope everyone
gets what they want this time we have so
much quantity of everything that's all
doubt but the truth is you can't always
get what you want but we're trying to
make it so but if you try sometimes you
just might find you get what you need
which is the morning to a sorority
crewneck sweater sometimes all the time
okay back to Lauren Elizabeth let's
speed up it's 2019 I am a big fan of
yours you are an Instagram YouTube
influencer clothing designer you really
are someone a jack-of-all-trades and I
feel as though you are like epitome of
an influencer you know what I mean like
because you really do it all and it's so
interesting when we talk because I think
of you as an instagramer year revolve
you have like such a great vibe on your
Instagram but you think of yourself
really as a youtuber and like the core
of your business you say is doing you
know - yeah yeah in this time and now
you're about to be podcasting so it's
about to change for you I can't wait to
ask you this question next year next
year but like where do you see the
industry going like what are you seeing
happening right now and like where is
this wave taking you where our brands
putting more money well it's interesting
because the the brands now look we are
like making more money from like
Instagram and stuff because since
stories and it's not quite gotten to IG
TV yet I think it will the next couple
years GTV I I didn't I tell you this
that I like uploaded the video and then
I [ __ ] up because I didn't preview it
yeah yeah and so that like screwed me
over but I'm gonna start like doing it a
little bit more yeah because I'd be easy
for you because like sometimes it's like
you see it on your feet and like you
just keep watching it's actually it's
easy like I'm addicted to Instagram so
why wouldn't I and I put like so much
effort into my stories so I would like
it's competing content for your YouTube
like no because it's I feel like it's
more short-form yeah whereas like my
vlogs like people love long-fought like
you would never put a 30 minute video on
IG TV it's more diverse in it yes isn't
10 minute max yeah yeah yeah
whereas like my YouTube videos people
love when they're at least like 2030
it seemed to chisel ah morning toast
exactly so I feel like it's just
interesting cuz like YouTube has changed
so much and it's it's you know like
we've been out here doing it since for
years and years and years and now all
these different people are popping up
for different reasons and I like that
there's been this shift back to now like
it was like all this drama and all these
like vlogger and everyone was like
youtubers man but now it's really like
starting to get taken seriously yes well
it's it's actual news now yeah just
really what we wanted to talk to you
about because you really find yourself
in such a precarious position because
you really know a lot of the youtubers
that like we're obsessed with and
whenever we have a question weren't
always like what some a chamber look
like you know like and you have been in
the YouTube space for so long you know a
lot of these people I know used to be
friends with Logan Paul right oh yeah
you told us that when you first came up
with morning breath that was like right
when it happens yeah
and I just want to get your take on all
these like drama
the Jacqueline hill and then the catotti
Charles and all that you know what I
mean like all the new beauties they're
coming all that stuff like becoming
mainstream news and like obviously where
you fall in each situation like do you
live for the drama and like the drama
channels on YouTube but you everybody
started a Drama channel I live for the
drama likes don't act live you don't
know me I live for the drama did you
watch the Shane Dawson I'm Jeffrey stark
I haven't watched that yet but I was
like literally like if anyone knows I
live for the drama
if you look over there I was watching I
watched all the James Charles Tati stuff
it's funny I'm I'm 99.999 percent sure
that three years like this is like the
epitome of my career like I hiked you
know what I mean like if this podcast
doesn't like bring me back right now a
[ __ ] issue like I'm telling my mom be
like save a bed look I might be moving
home and I bought a car today so by the
way I'll tell you all about it oh did
you drive it here no and I Drive your
car home yeah I have a license I swear
wait are you sure I swear I swear I'm
the only one with a license okay and I
Drive pretty regularly I just like want
to drive a Porsche okay anyway so okay I
peaked what was I saying I peed you were
ninety nine point nine ninety nine
ninety nine percent for that I was at
something called
generation beauty which like there's
been this is how much the industry has
changed like this was a thing once like
beautycon was like meh and then there
was like generation beauty and like
whatever one of the managers that I'm
friends with in the digital industry
came out to me she's like my client
really wants to meet you and she brought
over James Charles and he was like oh my
god like I love your videos like did it
like how would I mess that up in my
memory how would I like that's why I'm
saying 99.9 cuz like I am [ __ ] stupid
yeah and but like member stuff how would
I not remember that face and he was like
so nice and whatever but like now it's
like it never happened
do you ever see him no but like he
doesn't follow me like I think I've
definitely like walked by him and in the
past whatever I'm [ __ ] obsessed with
him with my sister's phone case like I
love him so much and he almost came on
the show this week but he was in New
York I know he wanted to come on the
show but when he was in New York and
obviously the one [ __ ] week we're not
in New York were in New York every day
for [ __ ] live we're here about it I'm
obsessive so in all the drama like how
did you feel when it was all unraveling
in real time it's so funny cuz like I'm
still like so irrelevant enough to just
be like adjacent like it's like when the
whole like Logan Paul thing will happen
people like Bullock maybe come on to my
page and be like oh my god like you're
friends with Logan Paul and like I also
like had like a contractual obligation I
shot a movie like three years ago with
him with him and I had to post about it
a [ __ ] month ago and so people were
like coming at me being like how are you
did it I'm like could you not realize
that I like to secure two bag three
years ago and like that have to like
knock it select like they literally
would not stop texting me and I will
like you know you get a thing you know
[ __ ] I got to do a brand deal I just
like stopped I just like didn't respond
until like I like got in trouble and
they were like you need to post about
the movie wait oh my god [ __ ]
so are you two not talking no we're not
fret the last time I saw him was a few
years a couple years ago was it over
after his big like I have not spoken to
him after like the controversy right I
like worked with him one time like he
was always like good to me and like nice
to me but I just I I kind of found like
a different group anyway yeah and
there's so much drama with it and also
like a lot of [ __ ] they do is really
fake so is it yeah I go out of like the
drama stuff is just it's not real like
when he stole the girlfriend from the
brother or whatever yeah it's like it's
it's heightened and it's like Tana and
Jake like yeah that's not [ __ ] real
they're not very real and you heard it
here for
first jakey's has a show coming where
he's like The Bachelor yeah no he's
getting divorced and it's all gonna be
like a big publicity stunt for the trash
lair which is his new show coming up
should me I mean I was like wait no it's
a brilliant answer this whole thing is
so stupid I just forgot to tell her that
I found that out yeah it's like none of
its real and like maybe like parts of it
are but like you see all these people
like out like if you want to see them
like go to her tonight oh man I can't I
know we're not we're going somewhere
else oh this is going up a Monday okay
can we take some questions that we got
for you from the toasters who obviously
got pink everyone keeps asking me that
um when you do ask me a question on the
Instagram feature you have the color
wheel comes up and you could change it
to any color you want
speaking about pink so like would you
ever be caught dead in pink yeah you're
not pink up you're not it's like kind of
Pinot it's not aesthetic it's like brown
okay
it sounds like Duty neutral no okay I
like I had like a realization that you
could get away with like wearing nudes
all the time and I'm like so into it and
I'm here for it but I do love pink like
pink is one of the colors that I will
wear
okay would I be caught dead in turquoise
probably not who I loved her I love a
turquoise also I would just look like
Cher as like just someone who's obsessed
with flow and aesthetic like your vibe
is so vibing what do you use to edit
your photos and and so there is those
stories are so premium holy [ __ ] so
there is a full tutorial on youtube.com
search learn elizabeth i uploaded how i
edit my instagram photos and stories and
it's actually premium like i spill a lot
of like apps you know what I mean
whatever apps so I love this app called
face tune you came to the right place no
I used like the teeth whitener you're
all my backgrounds so I make every luck
mirror pick you see like his why end and
then I go into teza app and I'm sorry I
don't use Jackie O flow yeah hey if you
had any like be download yes I put it on
my phone it's yeah you wouldn't like
there's nothing for you to do with it
okay and that's okay I feel like I could
figure it out though I know it's like
bright colors and you want like muted
neutral but I use like I'll show you
what I do like with the teza app because
it makes my like like face orange I
don't know and then I do you actually I
love an orange face yeah yeah looking
like I can't do an orange head
my hair's right that's like that's why I
had to make my own presets because I
couldn't use blogger presets because
they like to bring out the orange and
everything and it looked like a Cheeto
but see it's like I like looking tan but
I don't like like orange II background
so then yeah my boyfriend would always
be like you desaturate everything too
much like you're so much more beautiful
when you're glowing and i was like oh my
god do you think I'm beautiful why all
the time wait what like I literally told
him I was like you texted me saying I
was cute the other day and it was like
so nice you need to relax when you like
talk like that you know right
you get honorable like we don't like
post like screenshots to Instagram of
our like text combo well because it's
cheesy and that means you're hiding
something yeah well we won't dig into
that yeah I want to cup into a lot of
the questions that we got for you but
not before I let everyone know that the
second sponsor of the day is thrive
Cosmetics Cosmetics spelled CA USA
because it's a cosmetics with a cause
this is a new sponsor for us that I am
loved a also I learned about them before
they even became a sponsor because they
have a very compelling Facebook ad about
their mascara that convinced me to
purchase they have a very compelling
mangaccat about a highlighter for the
inner eye under brows situation I know
I'm talking about its it should be
called like a live girl by Jeff Bezos
because you look so a lot thrive
cosmetics products provide amazing
coverage they highlight your best
features and are created for
long-lasting wear all of their cosmetics
clinically are proven sorry all of
thrive cosmetics clinically proven
ingredients are free of parabens and
sulfates their products are effective in
more than just one way for every product
purchased thrive Cosmetics donates to
help women who are in need thrive those
causes include emerging from home the
homelessness surviving domestic abuse
and fighting cancer leaping bunny and
peed out the leading authorities on
cruelty free cosmetics have certified
thrive as a completely vegan and cruelty
free brand you can replenish your
product so you'll never run out of
thrive cosmetics essentials like their
liquid lash extension mascara which is
what I bought because I saw Facebook ad
for it or their buildable blur CC cream
who have to try that I love her there's
nothing I love more Apple it I wasn't
audible blur a couple weeks ago I was
doing my makeup for tour and Margot
comes into the bathroom I'm like how do
I look she goes oh just put on mascara
and in my kitchen I've been sitting here
for three hours putting on mascara I'm
like I just I don't know what
happened to my eyelashes and when I saw
the Facebook ad I really was like
compelled and it truly changed my life I
look like I'm wearing fake extensions
which I would if I could handle it I got
them done once and they like I'm totally
broke my lashes with rival cosmetics
products are great and it feels really
good to give back
you could start thriving and help women
in need by going to thrive cosmetics
calm / toast for 15% off your first
purchase
that's thrive cosmetics thri ve c au sem
et ICS dot-com / toast for 15% off
thrive cosmetics comm / toast
thank you thrive cosmetics for
sponsoring this episode and for changing
my life with your mascara sign on be
beautiful and give back also I see over
there learn Elizabeth it looks like
you're getting the hang of it oh yeah I
mean I was saying okay so we did a
little Q&A for you on our Instagram and
we got a lot of wide-ranging questions
and the one that really caught my eye
[ __ ] marry kill
Claudia Jackie Margot oh my god that's
so hurtful okay hold on let me think
[ __ ] my field Claudia Jackie Margot
okay this is tough because I already
know I'm going to marry Jackie O and now
I know me but then this is really hard
because like wait why are you marrying
Jackie just cares because like I think
like she like is like I told I told you
the other night when we were at so I was
like whatever you do I'm gonna do like
you're just such a good wife and I was
like I wouldn't leave just like Jackie
but like at heart I'm just like copy I
feel like you would marry Margot because
you guys have so much in common like I
could totally thought guys like we just
never stop talking I'm like I want to
like marry up you know okay this is
really [ __ ] hard literally just about
to say this is hard because I said I
want to marry Jackie but how am I
supposed to choose because like snitch
is like really my best friend body is
like my like my like sister okay no
don't do it okay I hate this Docs
because now I'm like maybe I should have
married snitch lady I'm a damn grade Oh
I'm not really in recap you marry snitch
then you're the breadwinner that's I'm
saying take care of me yeah okay bye
picture is it a throuple Oh mom go
actually oh yeah pronounce her last name
sure George
she's French and it's really [ __ ] no
it's not I say menage wha that's
definitely not okay this is a great
question from n schraeder 86 did you
know about any of the stagecoach drama
since we you were there with them 1000
million [ __ ] percent you did well not
like to the extent like what's happening
but a we were all there so like we all
like saw a lot of interactions happening
we all got like you know a little taste
of some personalities yeah and then I
found out about obviously the Blake and
Kaelin stuff before she left for
Paradise because she told me but she
didn't tell me what was going on well
you're a big bachelor fan and watcher
does it change how you watch a show
being actually best friends but do you
think we know them because we've met
once but you know I'm actually like
actually pissed about it like I kind of
like at first it was like cool now I
don't wanna be friends with any of you
anymore yeah because I want to make fun
of the show so bad like I just met tisha
who's gonna be here any second probably
and I was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] like did I
say anything bad about her like I can do
like a man of stayin and Kaitlyn
Bristowe and Laura Bush now all day long
they're out of it but it's like we're
not hitting too close to home yeah yeah
and it's like then when I wanted to like
make fun of something like Blake said
who like who knows I might be friends
within a few weeks right um right great
you're going at the right I'm going
Colton is knocking down cakes in your
backyard yeah exactly and it's like I'm
I want to make some jokes you know and
it's like how am I gonna and then I like
honestly being friends with you was like
affecting us shut up no because I want
to make jokes by people about to take my
friend Lauren's friends with them no but
it's like it's fine like I'm over here
trying to like be as good as you and
like filter what I say cuz don't it's
such a hard line to watch it get so hard
and it's just like if I'm like make fun
of Blake everyone's like you're jaded
because you're friends with Kailyn I'm
like they think that says to him like we
met her one yeah no people him talking
you said it's yo biased cuz you are best
friends of Kailyn I'm like I wish I was
[ __ ] best friends with Kailyn maybe
I'm saying all these things because I
want to be friends right
um is it true that you have chronic pain
yes you do yes she did I mean I only
know what that is from the Lady Gaga
documentary oh yeah yeah and she suffers
from it too and she literally is like a
full-time masseuse with her yeah well
I'm not I'm right I already peaked I
know what she said was that
honestly she was crying too she was in
so much pain and she's like I'm
literally crying because I'm thinking
that all the people who are going
through what I'm going through and can't
have the luxury of having a full-time
masseuse everywhere I go can you tell me
what that's like and what she said it
started from an injury on her hip from
dancing ya know I never got an injury I
just like remember when I was really
really young I had knee pain like
throbbing in my knees so I cry when I
was really really little but then I was
a competitive cheerleader so it spread
throughout other parts of my body so it
made it worse for my like the stretching
and stuff and so I basically just get
these like flare-ups and it's just like
I could that's why I was always late to
school and stuff because I was like
rolling around in bed crying and like
there's nothing I could in it's not like
a shooting pain it's like a dis like a
radiating discomfort and it's like
almost like arthritis and so like
sometimes I'll get in my hands I get in
my ankles I get my feet I get like
really tender so it's like some people
think it's like psychosomatic wait I'm
so sure I think I've crying it's not
pain it's just like an awareness of like
you're but like I I have chronic pain
you guys know ever since I was a child I
got those leg pains that would wake me
up in the middle that is charley horse
it's not a charley horse I get charley
horses it's the cramps in my legs that I
thought was from a potassium deficiency
that's you wait it doesn't feel like
cramp but like you could have cried you
know let's just like robbing awareness
not even like a pain just like an
annoying feeling ya know it's like it's
like I can't like function now okay so
maybe maybe have like like a low level
yeah I'd like a calcium deficiency
because I get that on the back of my
knees ever since I was younger and I
dude yeah I have the calcium deficiency
because like what am i or you're like
sensitive to a food and you're on
allergic and it like cause and causes
inflammation perhaps oh and we get the
inflammation at Snitch and I talked
about which you actually would I have
warmed up yeah when we eat and drink too
much and we get really tender and we're
in pain it would be this high words it's
because like Zack LeMay ssin from eating
like salty foods and drinking alcohol oh
you know what I did press on Tuesday
where they played this like stupid
little game with me and it was actually
really fun and I want to play it with
you okay it's called first and last it's
not called stupid little game yeah okay
so it's like personalized what was the
last thing you googled you could check
your phone mine was Phil's coffee and
guess what we didn't get it mine was
paparazzi Claudia oh that sucks what was
yours let me just click view all okay it
was Los Angeles parking office cuz Sam
learner needs to know where to go get
his permits then it was ceramics classes
near me because I need a [ __ ] hobby
according by therapists and then it was
chick-fil-a New York when were you in
New York I wasn't I wanted to prove to
someone that chick-fil-a was in New York
recently what I'm who is the most recent
celebrity you've teamed with hmm well
she like her friends are select right
look Joan they don't count
they're not real um who's with lepree
since Larry you teamed with um well on
the thing it was for um young Hollywood
I lied you did I said one in Paltrow
because Judy I'm with her like last week
and I just I needed that out minor just
like all like your friends who are
famous but you don't consider them
somebodies yeah I got all my target
celebrities like my meeting mine is
Kailen yeah Miller Keys writer ice yes I
guess I ain't my friends what's the last
text you sent oh god he's been sending
them all episode yep oh Jesus she's
addicted to her phone she said it
herself
I haven't texted anyone but I have a
text from Cameron how is Cameron he's
good he's in Florida oh he's visiting
his grandparents cute and it's like
super cute but it's like why the [ __ ]
would you leave like that you know yeah
October's my invite I hate when bed like
does things you know yeah and I just
like did you not like think of me before
you decide to do this thing can you give
some good tips on how to elevate your
style on a very small budget yes so the
biggest tip that I have is you go on the
web sites like the bougie or web sites
right and you see all like the trends
and like the newest arrivals and like
you see what what the vibe is and then
you go to the lower-end web sites and
you find those things that look similar
so like I'll see like trends that I like
and then I go find it at Zara that make
sense yeah cuz it's like then you're
like on trend didn't like looks really
nice and then if you do have like a
little bit of a budget like getting like
one like staple like Gucci loafers will
like go with everything but you can wear
this is Zara and then
okay these are evolved but I didn't pay
for them so like it's like on a bike
cheaper than sorry we're free free
counts free a lot of people
want to know how you became such good
friends with Cassie and Colton okay so
let's stop calling everyone my best
friend let's let's like let's like keep
that to to just us for just like us like
I just like I don't want you guys to
feel like you're on the same level like
these are my best friend okay yes I have
some from back home Nana and Co yeah and
UNK oh yes so the best part of our
friendship is that when Jackie and I
took a trip and Olivia took a trip to
Nashville two years ago almost three
years ago I know that the morning it was
the morning yeah ma ma our first words
ever one of the nights you know we live
for Nashville and like we live too
honky-tonk and we found ourselves
honky-tonk and down Broadway like [ __ ]
wasted the three of us having so much
fun of me ran into this group of girls
who were listeners to the show and they
were just like such cool girls that like
we would hang out with ordinarily so
like we did we hung out with them we
spent the whole night with them running
around town but our hopin honky-tonkin I
was [ __ ] sloshed like FaceTime them on
the show the next day like we kept in
touch we were a sorority before we were
the official mourner who we were joking
that like we finally felt like we found
a place in this world like for our
sorority like it was so much fun to me
touch you good night it was like really
like soul sisters and it's even crazier
like how much that was meant to be
because it turns out that they're one of
the girls or maybe two of the girls well
one of the girls is Lauren's like best
friend from home yeah and that's kind of
how we first connected cuz yeah I was
like instagramming I'm like I met my
name as friends and udm you were like oh
my god that's my friend yeah yeah I met
my new best friends it's like that's my
best friend Oh
actually actually I went I was in a bar
and I had to pee and Anna came with me
and she goes you know my friend Lauren
Elizabeth I'm like I'm idiot I follow
her on Instagram she said let's FaceTime
her and at least I'm you okay so while I
was literally peeing and then you and I
had to UM that's really how like RDM
live in such she could foreshadow this
like now I talked to him FaceTime on the
toilet but it's so crazy like it's meant
to because actually felt like us meeting
those girls and I was like so meant to
be but then it was like even more but
that's what I always say to you is like
the fact that you like fell in love with
like one of my actual best friends from
home who's like those are like my people
right like much Chicago people it's just
it makes complete sense that like we all
became friends and then when I met your
friends in Vegas yeah we all became
friends and then like everyone's like
you kind of like talk like them or like
whatever I'm like because that's what
happens when you have a friend group
like and you know what I means you now
like you look - oh yeah by the way bro
such [ __ ] [ __ ] listening in the
car you guys been like yeah Lauren
Elizabeth all she says his bro and I was
like bro what the [ __ ] like dude how
could you dude what Cameron hates when I
say that but whatever and I said it and
Ben was like why the [ __ ] do you just
say that I'm like honestly I don't know
Cameron doesn't speak like that where do
you get that from bro dude is that a
Chicago thing or an LA thing I think I
think beau someone that's an amazing
question from caddie K okay I didn't
answer the question elbows a question
hasn't called oh yeah how'd you get to
meet them so my boyfriend Cameron is
best friends with Gregg Sulkin
which is how we you guys all know him as
well and his girlfriend is Michele
Randolph and so I became friends with
Michele through Greg because BFFs and
then I figured out that her sister was
on The Bachelor and then lo and behold
she won and then they kind of just got
popped into her friend group yeah and
they're sweet Michele's so cool she's
this they're they're honestly like the
sweetest girls ever in your professional
opinion do you think Olivia Jade should
come back to YouTube
ooh I do I think she's more interesting
than ever now well you know that this is
a controversial topic yes
specifically look for me I know so I
don't know I mean here's the thing like
does she need to know no is she going to
probably be like okay I don't think she
can right now because on trial once the
whole saga is over maybe she could be
like a Mischa Barton we're like we don't
hear from her Frankel why I did she goes
on the hills back Mischa Barton was in
my dream last night looking incredible
oh yeah was that on your Instagram story
no Oh snitch was talking about her okay
I was loaded it just came back to me I
like walked past her like she was going
into a club and she looked fabulous in a
red wrap dress I can't believe how much
you guys liked her on the hills like I
wasn't even that big of a fan you worry
well it's not like it's there's nothing
to like he was like oh my god she's
amazing I'm like what am i her i loved
my expectations were so low and it's
like why are you here and she had to be
so great in order for me to be like for
her presence to be justified but like
watching her than the audition was
painful so pinky you audition you know
what it's like right do you go to
auditions kind of frequently nothing but
not not as much anymore but I've been on
a lot and they're absolutely horrific
horrible and I hate them and watching
her do it and like
knowing that like she's like a real like
actor like I'm over here like you know a
fraud I know it's like well she has to
audition I was like oh my god like no no
no make it stop and she's like I think I
got the movie and I'm like obviously you
didn't they're filming it for the
[ __ ] hills like oh my god like it was
as someone who's not an actor whatsoever
it was just like a patron of the hills
like she did it one way the director
gave her no actors yeah I literally was
because I got saimin Olivia to watch it
too and I was like you guys it's so
cringy but then she takes Direction like
a bum she's an amazing actress yeah I
think so too again ain't nothing like
she should have gotten the movie yeah
there's no way what casting office is
gonna let you come in and [ __ ] film
that's it's like come on let's think I'm
glad everyone agreed that the acting was
there though 100% um so before we wrap
tell everyone what they can expect from
mood podcast with Lauren Elizabeth it's
dropping every Wednesday it is according
to be gonna be you and your famous
friends you write Cameron when you know
Cameron we need jet Joey King on an
episode yes he'll everyone what they can
expect from it and yeah what is all I
use you to do it so what inspires me to
do a is well first of all I can clearly
talk just as fast and as much as you
guys and you know I've been vlogging
forever and it it came to this point
where I'm talking to the camera so much
I'm like really what the [ __ ] is the
point of this visual element like I can
talk all day I don't like getting ready
I can't believe you guys told me we
weren't [ __ ] filming this and here we
are so I put on makeup I was very upset
about it and it's fine we just want to
give you the full treatment thank you I
appreciate it and so I was just like I
have so much to say and I love listening
to podcasts and it wasn't one of those
things of like Oh everyone's making a
podcast like it's my turn like I only do
things if I like genuinely want to do
then like people were when you were
writing books and I was like I don't
nothing to [ __ ] write about yeah
right so I genuinely have wanted to do a
podcast for the past like a year and I
just kind of like being that Chicago
girl like living in LA and like in like
this really like fake town I'm doing air
quotes
fake town and being like a real girl
also air quotes and just like kind of
like my life in LA but also like
commentating from my perspective of
what's going on so it's like a
combination of
it's it's everything at first I was I
tried to pigeonhole it and I to prove to
my management - I was like what do you
want my POC has to be about it was
everything I already talked about so it
was like mental health fashion Real
Housewives relationships your friends as
them like it's why I was like that's why
I just [ __ ] mood like whatever it
feels like whoever I'm talking to you
like right there's something going on in
the world we want to talk about it
what's going on in your life what's
going on in my life and just like in
conversation with like not interview and
also I have so many interesting people
in my life that aren't just like the
Joey Kings and the same learners and the
Gregg Sulkin it's also like my mom has
such an interesting story I know
producers they're by it only influenced
her a long [ __ ] said that too like the
CEO vital proteins they all know my
family they're like based in Chicago and
her mom was like it runs like a PR
company and it was like she was like the
first booty in Chicago and she like
really was very impactful so I was like
- the guy was named Kirk I was like Kirk
she comes from a long line of influence
there's just like yeah so I think what
you can expect is just like almost like
the LA version of the morning toast but
more like in conversation like casual
like you know you guys are morning show
host I'm like a late-night like it on
the couch like look bring it bring it to
you live from LA
that's like one with all my friends and
like I'd love to like do an episode
where it's like my brother in Cameron
yeah or like my grandma and let Joey
like you know what I mean it's like
really like I think I know good
personality like how we became friends
is like that's what I want to hear by
but Jax your child if I have a cha cha
cha it's so true well look out for it
it's gonna be available iTunes Spotify
all the places and I'm talking nervous
by the way I don't be nervous because
chose home support I'm scared new
episodes dropping Wednesday follow
Lauren on Instagram for all the updates
at Lauren Elizabeth also your YouTube
channel which is youtube.com slash Lori
Elizabeth okay so just search Elizabeth
and that's what it'll come up as we hope
you guys have a merch shop today at 3
p.m. Eastern Time get your merch join
the sorority like it hasn't gotten a yet
it's the softest [ __ ] on the planet yeah
from coming from someone who makes who
makes clothes clothing no ringing
endorsement we love you guys we will see
you back in studio in New York tomorrow
have a great rest of your day